what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
i just woke up decided to do a video on
the better bachelor he's actually one of
my new favorite youtubers like i
genuinely enjoy his content
it's titled sheila left her husband of
five months
found out he was really rich and just
testing her and she failed
what a day okay
he actually like i think he's so logical
i like him
better than kevin samuel's fret
freshen fit or like any other dating
nano spear
space i've found so far
guys welcome to better bachelor this is
joker with a face for radio and a voice
for
print you know it's a heartbreaking
story
when a woman leaves her husband
must have been really really bad
situation maybe he
was terminally ill maybe he was a bad a
bad guy
treated her poorly or maybe he was
was poor yeah i dumped my broke husband
only to find out he's rich and was only
pretending
and now i'm upset
so you were fine with leaving him right
up until
he found out he was hiding all his money
from you and now you're upset because
you don't get any of it shocking
yes that's right she her name is eunice
um
it's so interesting to see these
women that are such gold diggers and
hear about this stuff because
i'm just someone who's very cheap but i
also
grew up in a position where i never had
to be like
desperate for money in any kind of way
my dad's always taught me
to like you can make your own money you
don't have to rely on someone so it's
really interesting to like
see these girls that are absolute gold
diggers had a husband that didn't have
enough money
appearing appear apparently didn't have
enough money for anything
and so she decides to leave him she said
that's it you're dead b
i'm out she leaves him and finds out he
was just hiding his money to test her
to see if she was a good money because
they were only married for a short
period of time
let's go over the story and
i always find it interesting because
chris rock has said it it's it's not
what a man
is it's what a man can do for society
for a woman for a person you can't you
can't just be
a good man a a a
a good product for society and a
stand-up citizen
you have to provide something you have
to provide services you have to provide
provide taxes you have to provide safety
and by joining the military um you have
to defend the weak
except when they don't want you to
because that is also bad
i mean you know the list goes on and on
you can't just be a
man and be good enough so let's read the
story
well i genuinely feel like it's a moral
obligation
to work hard and create something with
your life
and i would argue that that's more of
what women are attracted to
i've always said i don't care if a guy
is a coach
right coaches don't make a lot of money
they're i mean i know there's like a
select few that do but just in general
not the best like
career path right in terms of money but
if he's building something he's really
ambitious he works hard at what he's
doing
that's attractive to women and jordan
peterson even talks about
how it's usefulness that women are
attracted to like men that are useful
and
like i think that's part of being a good
person like i think you have a moral
obligation to make yourself useful to
society
now this is from nigeria but
the thing is we know this is pretty
unilateral across the board there are
stories from
many countries but i wanted to read this
one because number one it's only a
couple days old
and number two is that it you know it
shows you that it's not just in
westernized countries where these kind
of things happen
so here's uh here's our story my name is
eunice i'm in great pain
and regret right now now i don't i don't
think obviously english is their first
language
um that being said it's very well
written it's just if some of the words
sound a little off that's why i think
i left my husband tundy just because he
couldn't provide for me the material
things
i needed to live large and affluently
like my mates that's right it wasn't
enough that he just
provided for the family he didn't
provide enough
for the family and she and this is what
you really question like what is enough
because i think of women that spend all
their money getting their nails done
getting their hair dyed
you know botox whatever it is is that
really
a long lasting like asset that's gonna
make you happy
because that's what i think of when i
think of like providing for you
she couldn't live high on the hog and in
in the lap of luxury
like her friends so she was maybe looked
down upon i abused him verbally
emotionally and
physiologically i made him feel less of
a man i made him feel really bad
about not being well off like other men
in our neighborhood
oh so she basically just really treated
it poorly
those are the things that we talk about
by the way that she
so she she verbally emotionally and
physiologically
right well we talk about this happening
to men all the time and
and people say no i just he'll just man
up
you need to man well he did man up and
he left but it does she even admits it
herself that she treated him very poorly
and again men are on the receiving end
of this stuff but that's for
a different video anyway she says my
friends didn't help matters at all
oh it's their friend's fault they gave
me terrible advice on how to put more
pressure on my husband in order
for him to try to be work harder as a
man
okay and this this is what i've realized
is that women
it's hard because i'm a girl so i'm like
part of the problem i guess
but women give other women terrible
advice
absolutely terrible advice do not listen
to your female friends
they a lot of times they're very
competitive and do not have your best
interests at heart and a lot of times
it's subconscious i don't think women
like
realize it but like naturally
they see you as competition we'd only
been married for five
months when i decided to leave just to
teach him a lesson because he refused to
give me
the five hundred thousand or excuse me
fifty thousand i asked him
for my christmas shopping i don't know
what the currency is
so it could be five thousand or 3000 i
don't know how many dollars what because
she doesn't
they don't have a symbol for the
currency so i don't know he offered to
give me 30k
begging me that the 30k was all he had i
threw the money at his face and it
scattered all over the ground and then i
spat on him and told him that was the
end of our marriage
oh my how old are they because
okay it
it's i think it's okay to like date if
you want someone that's like wise with
their money that doesn't just blow it
the first second they get it right
that's
totally acceptable but if someone's like
building something
and that's how you treat them that's so
wrong the next thing i did was to go to
our room and pack all my belongings
shattered uh shattered a taxi then
zoomed off
uh he was staring at me the whole time
with angry eyes but
he didn't stop me from leaving anyway i
was surprised
why would you be surprised that he
didn't stop you
you were being a bad to him
you called him names you spit at him for
not for him not giving you enough money
and this man's just laughing because
he's so rich
and then you're shocked when he didn't
try wait honey stay
no he should have been like please get
out
and that was the last time i saw my
husband she says i'm not surprised
i would i would never see you again
either if you treated me like that
she says however after a few months now
i've been hearing stories from here and
there
about my husband being a rich man and
from a rich family
i thought it was all a joke in that
people were just playing with my
emotions until i went to see things for
myself
he was not only wealthy but was the also
the owner of a multi-millionaire
company nara company how did she not
notice that before like i don't know i
wish i had more information like what he
did
because if he's the owner of a huge
company it's not like he's sitting
around all day i ran into one of his
friends who told me the whole story
he loved me from the very first time he
saw me but he decided to approach me
like he was just a common company worker
earning 60k and living in a one-bedroom
apartment he just wanted to test me
if i was a good woman and not the type
that would just be after his money
that is a smart man especially when he
has that kind of money and guess what
he found out exactly what type of woman
you are
you are what we call a gold digger
i cried and cried my eyes out and almost
fainted
when i eventually saw my husband oh now
it's back to the husband
instead of the ex-husband driving a very
expensive car with another woman sitting
in front with him
i wanted to approach him and beg but i
didn't know how i'm even going to start
begging him to accept me back
i need advice what should i do i'm
broken
so here's what basically says you should
just take that out
and move on i'll let me sum this up in a
sentence
i want an easy lifestyle that someone
else will provide for me
i thought this guy wasn't going to give
it to me turns out he could have made me
a rich woman
and now i'm heartbroken what do i do
she's not being heartbroken over losing
the man or the qualities of them
he his family and him now i don't know
how much of his responsibility
he was given in making this company a a
multi-million
nera company or nara company so maybe
he's just
received the money and he didn't have
anything to do with it but that's
doubtful if he's working there and if
he's a sharp
gentleman like it sounds like he is i
bet he had something to do
with the company being so successful so
it sounds like he's known dummy
so instead of being upset that you left
a good probably
probably a good man at least one that
didn't retaliate when you treated him
poorly
not only did you lose a good man you
learned a man that could have provided
for you
you you left a man that uh sounds like
he's very intelligent and successful
but at no point does she reflect you
know what i was
i'm just a bad person like i should have
you know now looking back on my own
actions i'm a horrible person
and i shouldn't have done this to him i
shouldn't treat anybody that way
no there's no self-reflection it was i
saw him
lots of money other women now i'm mad
yeah and it's so
interesting to me because i grew up in
like
upper middle class type area so like
this
this super gold diggers really did not
like exist i never like was in
the like miami like crazy like expensive
party scene
so like i don't even know any friends
that dated like super older guys like it
was always like
a guy your age kind of doing the same
thing you're doing you go off date get
married
but it's interesting to see these girls
that just like have nothing going for
them
don't have a job have just been pretty
and have made a career off of being
pretty and they see it going away
and so they just try to find a guy to
like provide the rest of their life it's
interesting to me because
i never i never had that chance sadly
and heartbroken now let's let's read the
post there's five comments
just short five he said bob says advice
become a better person you're currently
horrible beyond horrible
disgusting woman says mary i agree with
you
matt move on and learn from your
mistakes learn to value a person not the
lifestyle you think they deserve i hope
you can find peace within yourself
before you think of joining someone
else's life uh someone else says love
does not exist for her empty shell of a
human
and a guy named steve says you f'ed up
move on
so you know this is this blows my mind
but not really okay there's part of me
that it just it blows my mind that uh
someone would do this but when i think
of the roles reversed let's say you're a
guy
and you're dating a woman who's
heavyset and you're not into heavy girls
but you get married to her and within
five months she becomes very heavy set
and is not attractive at all
and you decide to leave then she loses
all this weight
and becomes gorgeous absolutely gorgeous
and you turn around and
say i want her back is that the same or
different
um that's a good question
i'm not really sure because a woman
could say well i want a man because he
can provide
and he's well off and he makes my life
easy is that any different than a guy
saying you know what i want a woman that
i'm i'm attracted to
for this woman money is attraction i
guess for us for someone like myself i
might say i'm not into
you know a certain body type but if if
she's very athletic and slim
and proportionate i prefer that more if
she went from being heavy to that
does that make me a bad person saying
you know what um
i i like the way she looks and i'd like
her back
but only if she stays this way does that
to me
that makes me sound just as shallow but
the truth of it is it were i to be with
somebody and they
gained a lot of weight um i i think
i think i would probably not be happy i
you know i'd have to be
along the same lines the differences
here though is that she
agreed to marry him not on the premise
that he was rich and then became poor
and then became rich again
the premise is here that he already
was poor or not poor but well he wasn't
well off
that he was just an average bloke an
average worker and she may agree to
marry that
so i have to put it on her for agreeing
to marry him
as he is and as he represented herself
himself so
if he represented himself as a guy that
makes 60 grand a year
and she felt okay to marry that and then
gets upset because he wouldn't spend
more than he could afford on her that's
on her like he didn't pretend to be a
millionaire and then pretend to be she
didn't know
so i don't know i just find it i just
find it fascinating the fact that
that she thought she was going to marry
an average guy
but she was going to have this rich
affluent life like where was he going to
get all this money
and now that she found out that she
actually missed out on it only then is
she upset so remember guys it's not
you know when i say to young men that
want to date um a lot of times
look if you're if you're a good-looking
guy and you're athletic and you're tall
and you all the other things that women
love
you've got your easy street because
because women only want the best of the
best the cream of the crop
you're going to have selection of women
but if you're just an average guy
and you say hey maybe someday i might
like to get a family or
even i want an easier time dating
money is power money is attraction for
women now that doesn't mean you have to
spend it on women
but you having a nice fancy car and you
being able to comfortably go out and
take her out to an expensive dinner
she'll find you more attractive than she
will everybody else now that's not
necessarily the type of woman that i
would ever want to date
and that i would want to have any
interaction with
but if if at some point you do want to
have interactions with women
you have to remember too if you're
spending that type of money
early on like water you're gonna keep
spending more over time
where
like you know what i'm saying like if
you start by spending like a 400
dinner on the first date that's gonna be
the expectation you're gonna keep having
to spend
more and more and more where are my
savers let me know in the comments
people that like a bargain i'll spend
money on
chipotle and smoothies
and you want it to be easy just be able
to provide a lot
and if you can provide a lot it's going
to be a lot easier than
guys that can't provide a thing the
difference is the woman that you get
is going to be a completely different
woman and if if she's after you for your
material possessions
you're going to get a hot mess and
you're going to deserve every headache
you get guys if you'd like to support my
work links below
this guy is like my new favorite reactor
he is so talented
very like i really enjoy the reactors
and like the dating
space reactors that aren't in the fast
life that aren't
you know just trying to hook up with
girl girl girl
girl girl because i think that takes a
toll on your soul
and you can really tell the guys
that just sold their soul to live that
life basically
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree
let me know um what i should react to
next i know a lot of
you guys are asking me like for my own
content that's like what i think and all
this stuff
i will at some point but right now i'm
trying to like understand the manos
manosphere of space before i really dive
into that but don't forget to subscribe
leave a comment i'll talk to you guys
next time